- So Cheryl and Jesse each star in shows
that deal with awkward situations.
Jesse in "Modern Family",
and Cheryl in "Curb Your Enthusiasm".
And I also heard that Cheryl
loves game nights, so.
(Jesse laughing)
- I do, I do.
- I do as well.
Yes, it's very fun.
So we thought we'd see how they and I
deal with uncomfortable social
situations in real life.
It's time to play "Oy! That's Awkward!"
(Jesse laughing)
(quirky music)
"Oy! That's Awkward!"
It's pretty simple, we'll hit this button,
then an awkward situation will
appear with a couple options
on how to deal with it.
We each have rather to say which option
we'd choose in each situation.
So here we go.
I kinda don't understand it
either, but it's gonna be great.
(Jesse laughing)
So we're gonna
push the button, does it
matter how pushes the button?
Can anybody push the,
I'm gonna push the button.
- Do it.
(button clicking)
- Okay.
(screen dinging)
- Oh.
- [Jesse] Oh now you push
the button.
- Okay.
- No, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, gotcha.
(Cheryl laughing)
- Okay, so your boss
calls you by the wrong name,
do you A) correct her,
B) become a new person.
(all laughing)
- I think I'd just
roll with it.
- You would roll with it?
- Yeah, like, "Oh, hi, Tina," "Hi."
- "Hello," yes.
I like that name.
- Yes.
- My real name is Jesse Tyler
Moore, but Eric Stonestreet's
called me Jesse Tyler Ferguson,
so I just went with it.
(people laughing)
- Oh my...
- It's not.
- Would you correct the person?
- I think I would just get it
out of the way, right away.
- Yeah, I would have
to correct, 'cause I--
- Sometimes people think
my name is Jeffey.
- Oh.
- I was like, Jeffey's not
a name, is it?
- Yeah.
Sometimes people--
- Or Jesse,
or like the real name, like yeah.
- Sometimes people
say Clarkston.
- Oh.
- Yeah, and I'm like--
- So that's not it.
- But that's not my name.
That's not it.
- Sorry about that earlier,
yeah, yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- I feel like Ryan actually said that
when I won "American Idol".
- Are you serious?
- I was like,
did he say Clarkston?
Okay, I guess I do roll with it.
- Roll with it!
- I roll with it!
That's what I do, all right.
Next, you wanna hit it, go ahead.
- It has to roll, it has to scroll.
- Do we--
- I got this down.
- Okay.
- Oh.
No, I think we hit it,
and then it does it.
- Oh.
- Oh, you hit the button.
- You do not have it down, sir.
- I do not.
(Kelly laughing)
(bell dinging)
- All right.
A person exits a stall
in a public restroom
with toilet paper
hanging from their pants.
Do you, A) tell them,
or B) start whistling,
avoid eye contact, quickly
wash your hands and exit.
That's wrong, you need to tell someone.
Would you not?
- Well, I had a situation once.
There was a woman in the
bathroom, and she came out
and she had a long, it
was long paper trail.
And I said--
- How does that happen?
- Don't ask.
(all laughing)
- And I said, "Excuse me, but you've got
"some toilet paper hanging."
And she said, "Oh, can you get it?"
(all laughing)
- And I went into Larry David mode
and I was like, "No."
- No.
- No, I can't.
- And then my friend was
like, "You should've made
"oven mitts out of toilet
paper and gotten it."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, "Is that a..."
That's a lot, too.
- I'd have definitely said
hard pass on that one, yeah.
- Is it bad that I would get a lot of glee
out of going up to someone and be like,
"You have toilet paper
coming out of your pants."
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I'm kinda like into that.
Like, I like--
- Like, "I like bestie."
- Yeah, yeah.
Hey, girl.
- Hi, girl.
I'm totally the person to
tell you if you have a booger,
your zipper's down,
like your--
- I appreciate that.
- Yeah, I don't understand--
- Yeah.
- 'Cause when that happens to
me, or I get right offstage
from presenting an award or something,
and I have like spinach
or something or, well,
some type of sugar, it's not spinach.
(all laughing)
But whatever.
I have something in my teeth,
and I'm just,
who didn't tell me that?
- Yeah.
- I was just
on national television!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Those are jerks!
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but I wouldn't have touched
her toilet paper, that's wrong.
- That's a tough one.
- That's gross.